this is for those among us who are
secretly very stuck that is who are
entirely committed to stayin wholly
tempted to leave and entirely unable to
resolve their dilemma one way or the
other we the stuck ones alternate
between periods in which we managed to
convince ourselves that it might after
all be bearable and recurring crises
when we acknowledge that we are by
remaining well on the way to ruining the
one life we will ever be granted torn
between intense shame and untenable
claustrophobia weak in the face of our
conundrum we may start to fantasize that
someone or something else apparent the
government a war an illness a divine
command might magically resolve the
problem for us like desperate children
we hope against hope that something
might just show up but because it
behooves everyone eventually and with
nothing remotely unkind being meant by
this to try to become an adult but that
is a person who can alter their
circumstances through their own agency
we may well benefit from a few ideas to
strengthen our resolve for a start we
are here not because we are evil fickle
or just unlucky but at base because we
had a bad childhood this could sound
like an odd place to begin and the tone
may sound overly assured as well but the
matter does appear desperately simple in
structure however impossible the
repercussions can feel in practice
anyone on earth can end up in an unhappy
relationship but those who get badly
stuck in them those who cannot find a
courage to have a difficult conversation
and then move on those who spend years
feeling intensely ashamed of what they
want and doubting their right to aim for
anything more satisfying these creatures
are a particular subcategory of humans
they are the ones who when they were
little never learned the art of
confident self assertion they are the
Bur knighted creatures who never felt
they had
right at points to tell others what they
needed and to stick up for their vision
of happiness whatever the short-term
troubles that might be entailed we the
stuck ones with a good children the
under loved ones the ones who were
scared of angry parents or overly
anxious about fragile ones those who too
early on learnt to comply and obey to
worry about everyone else
to fit in and to smile and now decades
later the ones who cannot get up and
leave because we would at some level and
let's be clear on the matter rather die
than make a fuss but however appealing
that can sound the problem is that
there's a small part of us that won't
actually let us die like this that's why
we're here a part of us that awkwardly
refuses to shut up and be stifled a
healthy part of us that won't let us
continue without the kind of love
intimacy and closeness we crave a part
of us that is like a germinating seed
with strength enough to move aside a
one-ton concrete slab in order to reach
the light we endlessly question the
legitimacy of our aspirations is it fair
to want what we want is it normal to
seek whatever it is that's currently
missing and more love more intellectual
stimulation more friendship more sex
more solemnity more laughs we would in a
way so love someone to tell us that we
were plainly wrong but the reality is
that there can never be an objective
measure in these matters we want what we
want and no amount of arguing with
ourselves can make our appetites go away
or fundamentally D legitimize our needs
the way forward isn't to call ourselves
difficult and shut up but to learn to
honor and adroitly defend in front of
others our own inner complexity however
insane this will inevitably sound anyone
is allowed to find someone else's offer
of love to be in the end just not their
thing we are along the way naturally
terrified of being alone in our minds
by exiting this relationship we won't be
setting up a promise of a better
arrangement in the future we'll be
condemning ourselves to a lifetime of
isolation it's a feeling of basic
unworthiness and fundamental
unattractiveness that turns the prospect
of singlehood from what it really is a
minor inconvenience to what we are sure
it must be an ongoing and eternal
tragedy we should to calm ourselves
remember a rather dark but ultimately
consoling truth though we may at present
have someone to share a pizza with on
Sunday evenings we are where it counts
already alone what we fear might happen
has already happened we won't
by leaving be aggravating our isolation
will be taking the first proper steps
towards ending it stuck people are
agonized to the point of paralysis by
the prospect of causing difficulties
they possibly already have a lot of
hesitation about asking a stranger where
the bathroom might be so now they worry
whether the partner would ever recover
what friends would say how the family
would deal with it the last thing that
occurs to them is how much in the end
everyone just does cope the frightening
yet liberating truth is how little
anyone actually cares even the heard
lover is going to recover and will
probably come to appreciate the benefits
of freedom as opposed to enduring a
constant unmentioned emotional torniquet
around their heart an orderly life is a
beautiful and fine thing but it can only
ever be so when it sits on top of a
flourishing relationship rather than
when its fostered as an alternative to
developing one it's better to blow up a
home than continue in one unworthy of
the name the way to start getting
unstuck is via a properly strange
sounding move valuing ourselves a little
bit more slowly we should accept that
the point of a relationship isn't to
suffer that some things are necessary
but fewer than with
and that no one is going to congratulate
us on our deathbeds for having thrown
away our lives
we're not suffering because we need to
but because we have grown up to be
people for whom suffering feels horribly
and compellingly familiar we need to
take the entirely unknown step of
telling the world what we truly truly
want and dare to believe that we might
even one day get it our know yourself
cards can help us to better understand
the deepest most elusive aspects of
ourselves follow the link now to learn
more
you